[Music]
in the wake of Eric Chinaman's
resignation as Attorney General of New
York some of his longtime friends the
left are professing shocked you've heard
them we just can't believe it they say
how can a man so publicly committed to
feminism beat women it just doesn't make
sense but of course it makes perfect
sense self-righteousness is always a
marker for secret creepiness the people
yelling the loudest are usually hiding
the most keep that in mind the next time
you hear some Democratic politician
lecturing you about your moral
inferiority that's the guy you need to
watch carefully chances are he's up to
something awful behind closed doors
hypocrisy isn't just a feature of modern
liberalism it's the heart of modern
liberalism everyone now people who
advocate for abortion can say they stand
for children movement that demonizes an
entire race can claim to oppose racism
the same way Al Gore can travel by
private jet while trying to ban your SUV
because consistency does not matter to
the left only virtue matters we're good
people therefore we must rule you are
not therefore you must obey Al Gore
doesn't believe he's a hypocrite Eric
Schneiderman probably doesn't think he
is either you can't commit sin if your
intentions are pure and liberals believe
their intentions are the purest if that
sounds like theology and not public
policy that's because it is theology
modern liberalism is a religious
movement it's a replacement for the
Protestant Christianity that the left
works so hard to undermine and destroy
liberals are speaking the language of
faith albeit of faith without God this
is the main reason that right and left
talk past each other
the reason our public debates are so
weird and unsatisfying one side arrives
with facts and stats stats and arguments
the other brags about its decency one
side is trying to convince the other is
trying to convert you can beat a liberal
in an argument but you can never
convince him that you won
he cares much more deeply than you do
and therefore he knows he's right by
definition and nothing can convince him
otherwise somewhere tonight Eric
Schneiderman is marinating in his shame
probably unshaven and alone his career
is over his reputation is destroyed he
faces years of potential legal action he
is a broken man
he's in agony and yet on some level
despite all of that Eric Schneiderman
still knows he's a better person than
you are
Seth baron is associative City Journal
he predicted in public on Twitter that
Schneiderman would be exposed as a creep
and he said it last November
yesterday he tweeted this how did I know
this and New York City Mayor Bill
DeBlasio didn't great question we've
asked him to come on and explain stuff
Barron joins us tonight
Seth how did you know that that was a
remarkably prescient tweet thanks thanks
thanks talker you know to me it was just
kind of I thought it was just an open
secret I'd heard stories and rumors
about about Schneiderman for years I'd
been told by at least three or four
different people since maybe 2009 that
he is into rough sex with women that he
likes to date his staffers and is a
little pushy with them that he tried to
kidnap a reporter and one let her out of
his car on the way to and said he was
taking her to his apartment so I sort of
assumed that this was just you know
common knowledge more or less
now I'm not deeply involved in Albany
politics or in New York City democratic
circles I'm an editor for a moderately
conservative magazine you're not exactly
in the loop at the highest levels of
progressive New York is when they say no
exactly so that's why it seemed strange
that everyone was saying oh my god this
is the craziest thing we've ever heard
but it's clearly not I mean so that you
raised a really I think central question
which is if you heard about it is it
plausible that the governor of the state
one of his closest allies presumably one
of his closest friends Andrew Cuomo had
never heard of it
it seems implausible to me I mean it
seems impossibly implausible to me that
any elected official in New York State
hadn't heard it I I don't know what I
can say I mean Andrew Cuomo has been you
know steeped in New York state politics
for 40 years he basically has a private
arm
he keeps tabs on everything and everyone
he's extraordinarily paranoid yes I know
so I would imagine that he would know
everything that everybody's up to at all
times
he's a thoroughly bizarre person I've
dealt with him no I exactly the word
that comes to mind and I don't use it
lightly he's paranoid he's a control
person there's no doubt so this is a
little strange though because
Schneiderman was the Attorney General he
wasn't just some functionary he wasn't
the knight city editor at the Daily News
I mean he was the chief law enforcement
officer of the state so there's a
suggestion that he kidnapped somebody
you'd think that one of his peers would
follow up on it well you might think so
but at the same time he be I mean the
New York State Attorney General has
unique powers and is an immensely
powerful figure I don't think any
attorney general in the any state
attorney general across the country has
the kind of power that the New York
Attorney General does however if you
notice over the last few years in New
York State and New York City there's
been a lot of corruption investigations
yes but he has not been leading them
they've all been largely done by the
feds
there's trials going on in Albany right
now over you know Sheldon Silver's gonna
be retried a number of Cuomo's
associates just where Joe Percoco was
just convicted this was federal and in
New York City investigations of Bill
DeBlasio were largely being it done by
the federal government kind of funny
meanwhile this guy is suing everyone
about global warming or coming up with
with ways to have pardon proof
indictments of Trump associates or suing
the vitamin industry yeah
meanwhile the the cesspool around him
goes on addresses it Seth it's thank you
for that dispatch from New York not
heartening but fascinating thank you